My grandfather who is kind of the
intellectual in the family, a very
learned guy, also very active guy, always
taking me out ballroom dancing.
He started to show changes right around the
time I decided to go back to school.
No one really thought about Alzheimer's, this is
back in the kind of mid 80s, but as
I start to learn more about what was
going on I start to realize this is probably
Alzheimer's disease and at the time I
went to medical school and he actually
passed away during my second year of
neurology residency.
Like many people who
are young, I had never heard of Alzheimer's
disease, but it only takes somebody you
really love to see what it can do to
make it very important.
Alzheimer's disease is amazing in that it
really robs you of who you are: your
memory, your personality, your higher
level things, and leaves everything else
intact. So most people with Alzheimer's
disease can still talk and walk and feed
themselves, at least in the beginning, and
they look normal, but they are losing who they are.
The A4 study is really the
first of its kind to try to treat
Alzheimer's disease in its silent phase.
When the brain is beginning to build up
the changes we associate with
Alzheimer's disease, in particular this
amyloid plaque buildup, but before they
have any symptoms and that seems very
crazy in Alzheimer's disease because it
hadn't been done, but this is exactly what
we do in heart disease: we find people
with high cholesterol and treat them to
try to prevent a heart attack or in
cancer we detect through colonoscopy or
mammography, cancer before there are symptoms
The Harvard aging brain study which we've
been now working for about six or seven
years, the very first thing that we saw
is that people had high amyloid in their
brains, even though they're still normal,
had a faster rate of memory decline and
that meant you could see if there was a
drug effect because we could look at
this rate of cognitive decline and say
could we bend that curve, could we
make people who have high amyloid levels
or amyloid positive look more like
amyloid negative people if we give them
a drug? If we treat people before there's
irreversible brain damage, can we prevent
the cognitive decline associated with
Alzheimer's disease?
If the amyloid plaque hypothesis is
right or partially right, we're now doing
trials at the stage of disease where
that's relevant and we also now have
some pretty biologically active drugs so
I don't know for sure if we will have
prevention or cure but looks like if we
can get just one hook in and make a dent
it will really change the field and so I
think we're going to see a glimmer.